seeing in Berlin but sukhothai Anwar uh
lock from Malaysia is not a typical
tourist he's here to garner support
using the pseudonym zeuner he published
caricatures critical of the government
in his native country now he could face
a 43 year prison sentence it is a dookie
for cartoonists to expose corruption and
injustice in anywhere in including in
Malaysia zeuner is famous in Malaysia he
recently tweeted his support for an
opposition politician for the
authorities that was apparently the last
strong he was charged and could now end
up in jail for decades for alleged
subversive activities the law that this
verdict is based on harks back to the
colonial era his caricatures are caustic
regardless of whether they address
corruption or restrictions on press
freedom he refuses to be silenced
yes I was here I going to fish 43 years
deal I feel I'm human like anybody else
but if you ask yourself which is bigger
feel a responsibility for me
responsibility is bigger than fear
that's why he continues to fight for
himself and for freedom of expression in
Germany he is meeting with foundations
politicians and NGOs his objective is to
gain international attention and to
avoid prison zunar is no isolated case
in 2015 8 other journalists were
arrested and in February Malaysia's
largest independent online newspaper was
blocked in the global press freedom
index Malaysia ranks in the bottom
quarter zunar will also travel to
Britain and Australia to seek support
it's important for me to keep telling
myself that I'm not alone so I was
people around the world now supporting
me so this is the strength that i will
carry when I going back to bracelet his
trial is set for September if zune our
losses this could be his last visit to
Berlin